all right celeste and sebastian
celeste sebastian where did you guys
grow up where you from originally
celeste
originally i'm from kansas but i grew up
in nashville tennessee i moved to
nashville when i was like four
and so i grew up most of my childhood in
nashville
and sebastian
uh i was born in san bernardino county
and uh i was raised in east l.a
yeah
so spent most money you guys
so unless you came to la at what point
um
this time around i came in
uh september of last year but it's not
my first time living in la
uh i've spent like
time in and out of la and with your
family other places huh with your family
or on your own no on my own on your own
yeah what was your childhood life with
your family
um
when i was when i was a child
i was adopted at nine months old my
birth mother did drugs and she got me
taken away
um
and then i was adopted from within my
family
my
dad who adopted me is actually my great
uncle so
uh
i basically grew up knowing my parents
as my parents and not as my adopted
parents
but um
it was
it wasn't bad but it was definitely a
rocky uh
my
uh
parents
struggle with
especially my mom has struggled with
drug use like both my birth mother and
my adoptive mother um
and is like uh
part of the reason that i spiraled into
kind of an opioid addiction because
she
did opioids and kind of
like when i was really young she let me
try one because i had to pain and so
that kind of like sent me down that road
and me and my mother just had a like
really rocky relationship she would
just say
some nasty like mean things to me
but i you know realize that it's just
like from her own unresolved trauma
because my parents are both in their
late 60s so they grew up
like way different than i did you know
and
um they both have their own you know
traumas but
for the most part like my my family was
like together they just recently
actually got divorced like
this year which is kind of crazy
but uh
yeah it was
definitely a lot of like emotional abuse
and like my parents fighting like all
the time and
um
i was an only child too an adopted only
child so i was always like alone
so i kind of took the brunt of it you
know and uh
i
i didn't really get to express my
emotions much you know
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh in high school uh
in high school i was like uh such a
weirdo like i i've always kind of been
um
yeah an outcast i've always kind of been
an outcast
uh
like the first two years of my high
school experience i was definitely like
kind of like a loner and uh
you know didn't really like talk to many
people
but once i got into my like junior year
i started like getting involved more in
school i was like
i was in like the ag program and i did
like um
youth in government and i was in a play
and i did um
bnn which is like when you uh like do
the school news and stuff and i used to
be an anchor for my school news so it
went from me like kind of being like an
outcast
to like
being accepted because i guess like
weird kind of became cool and i ended up
my senior year winning superl the
superlative for like most unique
but i never really like had friends like
i was always alone and like uh
didn't really like talk to people like
that i just kind of was like known you
know for being that weird girl
and drugs started for you at what point
so drugs started for me at like i hate
to say it but like
12 like yeah um
like
you know i i've had chronic pain my
whole life
like my mom didn't give me you know her
drugs because she wanted to get me high
you know like i had chronic pain since i
was young and i was in and out of the
doctors having like this crazy stomach
pain having crazy like you know joint
aches and stuff like so much to the
point where like one year when i was in
elementary school my mom had to go to
truancy court because i wouldn't show up
to school so much
and so
because of all that pain my mom when i
was like 12
gave me like a pill and i remember the
first time she gave it to me because i
was watching mythbusters
and i thought that the reason i felt
good was mythbusters so i was like
watching that for a while and then i
realized like after a few times like oh
like the the pill is what make is making
me feel good and so i would like in his
opiates you know so i would like i would
start you know stealing her pills and
stuff and then like eventually like i
got into marijuana
and like i started smoking marijuana
like 13 12 13 too
and so i would like smoke that and
you know my dad was kind of unaware you
know but my mom i like knew i was
smoking weed and she
knew like she would give me like pills
now and then she didn't know i was
stealing them and like taking them they
were very unaware that i was stealing
them
but um
yeah uh
i
then like
later in in high school i started doing
[Music]
like um
nothing crazy uh i don't i didn't i
think i did like acid like once when i
was like 17 but like i didn't really
start like
heavy drug use until i was older but
from
the ages of
12 to 15 i was
i would say like addicted to opioids
like
i
would take them to school and take them
at school and i would like
uh just like
like it like they would bother me when i
didn't have them all the time and and it
was just like such an issue because it
was like it was right there in my house
you know what i mean and my parents
didn't know so i would just like you
know grab them and then eventually you
know you meet people that you know take
their parents drugs and then you buy
them off of them and
uh so yeah like opiates were like a big
big problem for me when i was that age
and then when i was like 14 i
uh like i overdosed in my bathroom and
like woke up like like basically like
i'm like almost dead i don't i don't
know how i woke up because i
like hit the toilet and like and i was
like 14 and i like i kind of like
uh no i was like i was 15. and i like
woke myself up and i was like okay i
need to like quit this but you know it's
been an on and off like journey with
opiates because of that you know and
because of like
my past of my birth mother also like
using sure in my biology or my adoptive
sounds like you were destined to do it
almost
and sebastian tell me tell me your story
you had both your parents
uh no actually i grew up so i grew
i grew up without a father my mom was
so alone i'm so sorry so
my mom raised me as a single mother
and
i grew up
and
[Music]
i grew up in a household that was super
abusive
mentally and physically
and
it just it was hard growing up uh
i don't know i didn't have much freedom
i couldn't go outside and play with like
the other kids and stuff and
she abused drugs she would use meth
around me and
uh just you know smoke weed around me
and like leave me alone and stuff like
leave me by myself in the house and
stuff and
um
yeah i mean
i don't know it almost feels like i was
destined to use drugs too because
i started using at a young age i first
smoked weed when i was 12
and then
yeah after that i started using cocaine
when i was like 13 and it was like
avidly i like i used it like a lot you
know and um i have adhd and i just i
don't know i i self-medicated a lot
because i
uh felt like it helped me in a way but
obviously it didn't really
um
yeah and i had trouble in school i was
always like the troubled kid you know
and i was just really misunderstood
because you know i i don't know i just
what didn't really have a good home or
any support
uh you know for my family
and i'd get in trouble with the law a
lot and um
i don't know just you know would bring
the cops to my front door a lot
and uh
what was it um
yeah
oh yeah um
yeah my
so my mom got married to this guy
and uh they had nine
nine kids together
and um
yeah he was like super abusive with them
and uh you know he he would leave them
alone and stuff you know just a lot of
like child neglect and stuff and then my
mom actually went to jail what was it uh
like late 2021
and um she lost like uh all my siblings
and they all went to foster care but he
actually uh their father just got
custody of them like uh it was like last
year
and uh i visit them every now and then
but i don't really talk to them
um
oh yeah and then um sorry thank you when
i was like 16 i uh
my he was super abusive towards my mom
and uh one day like he like hit her and
like like he like punched her and gave
her a black eye and he was trying to
like you know uh
hit me too and so i don't know i just
got tired of that and you know i was
like uh older and i had like more power
in my hands and so he was an alcoholic
and so i reached for like his gray goose
vodka bottle and like i smashed it
against the table just because i've seen
that in movies and i thought that was
like kind of cool you know and um
i i
like slashed him on the side of his uh
like i don't know lung or something yeah
like it's blowing right there um
yeah and he just had like this really
big gash and it was like i don't know i
was kind of dumb i did it in the front
yard and uh this like lady uh it was
like a nice quiet like neighborhood you
know so this like jogger passed by and
she was like
i guess she called the cops and she saw
that and my mom called the cops and so
did uh you know
yeah so then they came and um
i don't know i went to juvie for like
six months and that was horrible it
sucked
and then uh
after that i was on house rest for two
months
and uh this all happened while i was
like a senior in high school
and uh
yeah and then i wasn't i wasn't supposed
to graduate
either
but then uh i got most of my credits
while i was in there
and then uh
what was it when i
when i
so like the last day when everyone's
graduating
uh
my principal knocks on my door and i'm
here i'm thinking like i'm not supposed
to graduate
and uh
he was like uh
he was like hop in my truck let's go i
guess they're like a miscalculation of
credits
and
um i don't know i ended up graduating
yeah and that was that was that was fun
i guess it was cool and uh graduate yeah
i got to graduate
and um yeah i don't know where my high
school diplomas actually should find
that somewhere but
yeah
because i don't know
for a while yeah yeah we'll get to that
but um
yeah and then after that uh my mom
kicked me out she
she kicked me out like two days after i
graduated and um he was still 17. yeah i
was still 17 and i was like
three
two months away from being 18. uh and i
don't know i just
i didn't want to be there anyways
because like i said i grew up she was
super abusive
and you know
just like in every way like very and she
would put me down and physically abuse
me i remember like growing up i was like
uh what was i was like 11 when she put
my hand on the stove and would make my
sister watch and you know she i remember
just like going through a lot of just
like really psychotic abuse you know
like she would beat me with extension
cords and starve me and
uh just like horrible stuff that you
know like i don't know my my
younger sister got most of it she got
i think the words like mule mutilated or
something a lot you know he she would
like tie her uh tie her up and leave her
in the bathroom and then like piss on
her and stuff and it was really bad it
was horrible
um
and i i had to witness some of that but
i was young at the time i didn't really
know what to do i didn't think it was
okay but same time i didn't know like
what to think of it you know
um
like now that i'm older i know that it
was like you know that was not okay but
um yeah going back so you know when she
kicked me out i
you know like i was 17 i wanted to go
back home to my room you know and just
you know lock myself in there but i was
kind of like no it's kind of like a new
opportunity fresh start for me to like
figure things out on my own
and so when my friends had landed in
seattle i really like i like i'm an
artist i work on music a lot and you
know i like making clothes and stuff and
just reworking lots of stuff and so one
of my friends uh he flew in from seattle
and he was like hey like i'm in the
studio do you you know want to come over
you know i saw your post about you not
having nowhere to go tonight so that
night i slept in the studio and like
pumped out a whole mixtape that was a
really good summer uh what was that
summer that was summers
8 17 going into 18 or no that was i
think that was like summer 18 but yeah
um
and just since then i've just been like
uh you know staying with lots of random
stuff are you just like staying on the
street sometimes
yeah yeah i
i yeah just recently i think
he had more like luck when not to
interrupt you yeah go ahead when he was
like on his own like a little bit
younger like 18 and 19 you know like 20.
yeah but we since we've been together
we've like definitely like slept outside
like a good few times you guys have been
together how long seven months seven
months
how did you guys meet
the internet
and it's crazy too because i was here
last year uh
in summer of last year and i was
homeless and he was homeless and we
ended up like
going to the same shows and like like
being around each other in the same
scene and how old are you guys uh i'm
23. i'm 21. 21. yeah yeah and so
uh we just missed each other but we
followed each other on instagram and
it's kind of crazy it's one of those
things where i would look at his profile
and i'd always be like this guy's so
mysterious i want to like talk to him
and and he did the same thing like
and and then one day i moved here like
when i first moved here in september i
had a friend let me move in with her and
kind of like she told me you know like
hey like i'll help you out come come
move in which she
didn't really help i mean she helped me
out but she ended up screwing me over in
the end but um
yeah i'm i'm i was like about to go hang
out with someone else and he just uh
texted me like
he just i think i replied to your story
on instagram and he literally just had
come over like nothing else no
conversation he just said come over and
i was just like okay
and so like i even like missed a video
shoot to go over because i was just like
i was so like same music
oh that was the next day yeah no no yeah
yeah and i went over there and we we
hung out for a little while and we like
we talked on the the balcony um for a
long time about kind of drug use and
like bonding over you guys using the
same drug yeah well not at that point
but um we both had like problems with
with opiates and stuff
and uh
the
the next day or the day after something
like that i went back over there that's
when i missed the video shoot to go hang
on with him
and
literally like the second day uh he kind
of like
uh you know vented to me about how he he
used can i can
about how he used fentanyl and um and
like ended up like you know using in
front of me and i it was kind of like i
thought it was like a cry for help
because you're smoking so much that he
was like nodding out in front of me
yeah and um
and we ended up i just felt like you
understood me i felt comfortable
yeah it was it was one of those like
moments where it was just like
you know like you you meet someone and
they just like understand you like more
than anyone else and yeah we ended up
like
we ended up
kissing and like we ended up saying i
love you that night like it was it was
like really really fast and uh
we kind of just like took it like but
the next week we we
like we were hanging out in hollywood
and we didn't want to stop because my
roommate was
didn't like him for like past
reasons and so we couldn't hang out at
my place and he was living in a shelter
at this point
and so we went to venice and we slept on
the beach and then we hung out in venice
and then the next day we went to santa
monica
or we went to santa monica at night and
then we slept in santa monica and we
woke up and we like rode the ferris
wheel and this is this at this point i
was using a lot of ketamine
and so i was like i was like high on
ketamine like riding this ferris wheel
and
and we were just like we have like
pictures of us in like the ferris wheel
it was like one of those most like
magical days of my life honestly
so you guys are using the same drug now
yeah um like
uh
so at first when he was using like
fentanyl he was like
no don't use it like he he he really
like i really put my foot down i really
did not want her to use it um and you
know i
i just i couldn't hide it from her you
know like i would i have to i've been
using since like 2017 i've been using
for a while now like for four years
and so
uh you know i just i get sick i go
through withdrawals if i don't like use
within like the next like seven six
hours
and so there's no way of hiding it you
know like one time i was late to at like
for a date for us to meet up just
because i had to use you know before
meeting up with her you know and you
know it just got to the point to where
it was like
uh you know just i
you know you have to know that i do this
and you know
i might use it a friend of you you know
and i just don't want you know you just
i know yeah he tried to lie to me about
it the first day he tried to like he
tried to like tell me it was like wax or
something but i was like i'm saying
there's wax
but yeah and and he would smoke around
me and at first i was like i didn't i
didn't want to you know use it i wanted
to like help him get clean and stuff but
like you know coming from the mind of
like a past opiate drug addict you know
and i mean myself like i was like
i was like oh let me like blow the smoke
into my mouth and like i didn't like for
the first like october was when we met
and for the first month in october i
would just smoke occasionally and then
in november i would smoke occasionally
because i remember points in november
where i could go days without hanging
out with you
but
it was really when my friend kicked me
out
um
for
basically dating him it was
pure
like it was awful like she she she made
this promise to me that she was going to
help me out and that i didn't have to
pay rent like for the first few months
and i did i basically paid a thousand
dollars just to sleep on her couch for
two months and i wasn't even there half
the time because i wanted to be with him
and he couldn't come over
and you know and i mean she just had
this vendetta against him because like
you know past drama and like knowing him
through someone else and like you know
judging him because he's you know a drug
addict and
when she kicked me out i was like i
didn't like have anywhere to go because
like
my parents back home are like divorced
now and they're selling the house and
like uh don't really you know it's a
very toxic environment like you know
what i mean like at home with my with my
parents like uh
just
like
awful like
i i should tell the story about how when
i went to the psych where it is i want
to talk about my drug use
no you go ahead
yeah i just uh i wanted to pinpoint i
started using
uh opiates uh like a lot like every day
back like in 20 i started using uh like
early 2019 and it was just like oxy like
oxycontin and like uh you know what is
it vicodins and stuff like that and then
um
there is like these uh blue pills
they're called like m30s or like fake uh
what it looks like fake percocet would
you call it yeah and and they're pressed
with and all and i knew this you know
and i i i knew what i was like getting
high off you know and i just didn't want
to say it was phenomenal it was cool to
say like oh it's a percocet like it's
not you know it's like kind of taboo to
say it's fit and all you know and
um
yeah and then like one day and i was
using the blue pills for like a year
straight and then one day my uh like my
drug dealer i get them off she was like
oh i don't have any i didn't get the
shipment of them
but i do have like the key like chemical
that's like in them and that's fed and
all that's what you're getting high off
and so i was i was like okay and she's
like you should you know if you want to
uh you know get high you try this if you
want to get well and i was like okay and
so
you know i tried i was like super like
young and naive i was like you know 19
and i was just like looking for you know
and it's you know some relief and stuff
and so she invites me upstairs to her
apartment and i try it and then i was
like damn this feels good this feels
like 10 times stronger than what i
normally use which is that blue pill
that i was talking about and
uh you know at first i didn't know how
addictive it was i've i've heard of it
before i've had friends die from it but
i do i still yeah and then so
so still the same night i'm like hitting
it and i don't know you know what i'm
dosing myself with and then like all i
remember was waking up with her naked
i'm naked she's on top of me you know
and then like on the dresser there's
like a bunch of narcans and
you know when she's on top of me but
she's like sleeping and then i'm like i
wake her up and i'm like what just
happened and she's like well you died
last night you overdosed and i was like
what really because everything after me
hitting the foil i like blacked out you
know
she like completely took advantage of
yeah i guess like you know we had sex
but like i don't even remember it that's
not sex that's not consensual you know
what i mean he was completely sexually
assaulted so when someone narcans you
you like uh you whiff you go into like a
withdrawal state you know and you start
sweating and you feel like sick and
vomiting it's horrible especially so
yeah so like when you wake up from that
show i when i woke up i was i was like
uh like feeling sick and i was this was
like my second day in and i was like uh
you know how do i make myself feel
better and she was like oh you uh you
gotta like keep using to feel better and
so then that's when i got hooked you
know she you know gave me some more
phenomenal and i felt better and then
from then on i just i kept using and
using and using and yeah i just i i
don't know i've stopped at periods of
times like the longest i've been clean
for was six months uh that was sometime
last year but then i picked it back up
again um
i don't know i just
i i keep running back to it um i went to
treatment like last month was it
yeah we
we both went to like treatment and um
but
like i
i relapsed and i kind of like ended up
like making him relapse which like i i
feel really guilty about but like and it
was crazy because if they hadn't given
me suboxone i would have been fine but
they had given me suboxone and the
suboxone that i was withdrawing from was
worth in the fentanyl withdrawals
um
and i i i thought it was fine i like
leave because i was at this place and i
was having seizures and they didn't even
think i was having see
it was just not a good facility overall
and
like one of the main reasons i left and
this is like really [ __ ] hard to talk
about but um
the reason i like went in was because i
was pregnant and i i found out that i
was pregnant
and we we wanted to like keep the baby
and we wanted to like go through with
that because we were already like
working on housing and we were like well
if i'm pregnant we can get housing like
that you know what i mean and i have you
know good job experience and stuff i
used to work at amazon making like 50
000 a year so
like i i was like we can do this and um
i went to this facility and i and i told
them that i was pregnant and they ended
up giving me medication i wasn't
supposed to have you're not supposed to
take suboxone when you're pregnant
and um i ended up miscarrying in there
and um i like
where it was used to take you to the
hospital that night yeah and i and i
mentioned it to them too that i was
bleeding out and they didn't even like
take me it was
it was like a whole thing and uh
so
yeah we miscarried and i remember like
calling him at the hospital because i
had a seizure like a few days later they
didn't let us have phone calls at all so
i was stuck in there with like
going crazy and i called him at the
hospital and i told him like i i'm
pretty sure i lost the baby
and like i can't even tell you like how
he cried like he wailed
and
at the hospital like i confirmed you
know i like ask them like can you you
know
figure out if i'm you know still
pregnant and they were like no you're
not
and so like that was like really hard
and like once i found that out like
i left you know what i mean to be back
with him and i really wanted to stay
clean but i was like so weak and stuff
and and i wasn't feeling good and i got
suboxone off the street and i wasn't
helping and so i i ended up getting
smoking fentanyl and it you know and i
mean it just like it's a cycle and we've
been wanting to we keep wanting to go to
treatment
but we're like working on this housing
and so we don't want to be in treatment
and like
and how this housing and like it's just
like a few weeks ago it's like oh it's
gonna be this week and then last week we
thought we're gonna move it on wednesday
and then they were like oh there's like
hiccups in the paperwork but we're
supposed to be getting it this monday
like for sure like you know uh waiting
for la housing authority to send over
the leasing of the lease papers and so
we're excited about that is it difficult
to be in a romantic relationship living
this lifestyle
of course yes of course
sorry
um
when
when
like at first like when i was like
really just starting to get addicted in
december we decided like to to go to
nashville tennessee where my parents
lived for christmas
and um go to my house and we thought
that we could just withdraw there
without them noticing dumb
and of course like they noticed and so
like we withdraw we went through there
but like we we literally couldn't take
it like we were searching on the
internet for like fentanyl because it's
really dangerous to withdraw from
fentanyl on your own because it could
get like seizures and you could die
and so we were looking for that and then
we ended up finding somebody with oh
sorry to touch somebody we ended up
finding somebody with m30s and then we
like smoked those so we said bluegill i
was talking about really and uh so we
came back here and you know like we
ended up like using obviously and
uh
it was crazy because
uh it was right before christmas we we
go back there and we were gonna spend
christmas with my family and of course
like the the day after we get there his
housing manager calls and says
you have to be here right now
to sign some paperwork
and you're going to get your housing so
we're thinking we're going to go back
there on only wait like a couple weeks
maybe a month at most to get the housing
and it's been since that end of december
like there's so many times where we wish
we would have just stayed in asheville
and got like jobs and stuff because he
made it sound like oh you need to be
here in person like honestly you
probably could assign that paperwork
like forever later
like an estimate of like two weeks the
most a month you know and i was just
like okay let's let's do this you know
we hopped on a plane you know landed in
lax and then you know we've been waiting
like what like six months since and it
was it was crazy too because uh
on like we ended up spending christmas
out here because we didn't like we came
here like on the
21st or 22nd of december when we got
back from my parents house
and on christmas we used to sneak into
this like apartment building that we had
a friend that lived in there and there
is like this little like couch in like a
main area and we would kind of sleep
there sometimes
and we slept there uh christmas night or
you know uh the night before christmas
and the morning like i wake up and
uh we're smoking and i remember like he
was like giving me like little hits and
i was like let me get a bigger hit you
know what i mean because like i i was
just you know i wanted me to dose her
more than usual you know yeah and and i
i i died like i was out for and that
wasn't the first time i overdosed but
this was like one of the worst because
he said
yeah i have a bracelet that says thanks
for saving my life he's saved my life
like five six times now what's the
hardest part of this lifestyle
what's that what's the most like
that like like i that day when i
overdosed on christmas
he
like narcan to me what three times and
was popping my chest and most people
would listen to this and say i gotta
quit this lifestyle that's just not an
option right yeah i know yeah
like the
like he was pumping my chest and and
giving me narcan and
and what woke me up like he said like he
cried and like a tear landed on my face
and that woke me up
but
i was praying too i mean i'm very
spiritual believe in god stuff
and
the hardest honestly like the the thing
is it's like
we
do really want to get clean like we we
we've like tried multiple times and i i
think it's just like the fact that like
like we had like i i know that if i had
you know not lost the baby we would have
stayed clean like i have full confidence
and faith in that
but that's honestly why i relapsed
because you know i was really excited
and you know i you know really just went
cold cherokee and like you know admitted
myself into a treatment but then uh you
know when she gave me that phone call
you know i kind of
you know all of all i've ever known was
you know coping the pain with you know
opiates and so i kind of just like ran
back to that because i was like i don't
know how to deal with this you know my
you know my girlfriend's a treatment you
know she just lost a baby
uh you know um on the streets like i
don't know you know what to do you know
and and you know to relieve the stress
you know i just you know went back to
using it's kind of hard when that's all
you know you know like when you when
you've done drugs for so long especially
for like i know that you've like been
around drugs but for me like opiates and
like specifically have been a part of my
life for over 10 years now so it's like
so
hard now that i'm on a drug that's like
literally so physically addictive and as
an opiate because
when i was younger you know i was able
to like you know stop myself when i
started getting too bad and i was
spending too much money and stuff and
like
but
this time it's like you know yeah you
might die and you like wake up from
being narcan and you're in like the
worst pain of your life i remember when
i was in that room
when he when i woke up and on christmas
i was like i was in the most pain i've
ever felt in my life probably old sweats
fun
it was it was awful but
you know what i mean like we we
genuinely want to like stop it's like
but you have to we have to you know you
have to take genuine time out of your
life it's not just like you know what i
mean go through the withdrawals for a
few days it's like you know what i mean
you have to find a time so you know go
into a treatment and like make sure it's
the right treatment because when i went
into that treatment and all that
happened to me it's like now i'm like
more you know
because i was doing straight crazy you
know what i mean the first time that we
we started to detox by ourselves i know
we ended up like you know smoking the
m30 when we were back in nashville but
we spent two days doing it and because
we had each other and we you know had
our phones to distract ourselves we were
able to but in that and that and that
place that i was in i wasn't able to
have anything to distract me and i was
like just just going crazy you know
and it's
it's really just that like we were
waiting on our housing because we really
want to like kind of do it on our own
and like get go
like
we have a plan to go to this place for
the first four days take care of like
the initial like withdrawals and it's a
place where we can have our phones and
we can have like you know nicotine with
us and we can have like see each other
you know what i mean so we have those
like coping mechanisms um the first five
days are the worst so yeah and then and
then for the rest of the time we're just
gonna like you know
go home and we we you know we've talked
about you know therapy and and you know
and i mean going into like meetings and
stuff like that and it's just like you
know it's crazy because it's just you
get so caught up and so distracted in
life because it's like oh you have to do
this and then you have to worry about
this and that and you know what i mean
and sometimes just trying to take the
showers like a full a half a day task
you know trying to find some shower
but i think for the most part you know
it's just comfortability it's like what
you know you know it's just like
trying to break that cycle of of like
pain and like just trying to cope with
like you know
substances and like
because for me i i've always used drugs
like since i started using drugs can you
imagine a life where you weren't using
drugs
i mean i mean i can imagine it of course
you know like i i was
like an amazing like even even though i
didn't like ex like try hard i still
excelled in school i had like a 4.0 i
you know what i mean did amazing on on
my writing assessment while you're a
drug addict
uh yeah i mean at that point you know i
i was you know functioning like i was on
i was only doing you know marijuana and
like you know
other stuff you know but yeah throughout
my whole high school i ended up you know
excelling and you know i mean i even got
scholarships and i didn't because i had
i think
and i don't want to blame it on my
parents because i'm still my own person
but i was never like you know pushed you
know like i they never i i didn't know
what i wanted to do and i was never
steered in a direction and i was scared
because i grew up poor and i didn't want
to like be in college debt because you
know like even the scholarships like
what if they don't cover everything i
know they'll cover certain things and
like what if i don't want to do that and
i end up spending all that time and it's
just like all those things where i was
like too afraid to do that and i wanted
to travel and so like i ended up you
know moving to miami and like moving
into new york and like moving to
riverside california and like
i've spent times where i've made you
know crazy amounts of money and i've
been you know successful and um like
like just
like last year i was an assistant
manager like working at amazon and like
had was fixing conveyor belts and you
know doing a lot of like i'm like
amazing like work and i i was making
really good money and even at that point
i was using drugs like i was using
ketamine like i remember there was even
one time where i went to work and i was
using and i ended up performing somehow
i ended up performing the best out of
everyone in the building that day and i
don't know how it was it was hilarious i
like saw my name on the board and it was
like it was like uh number one person
who was uh stealing the best celeste and
i was like are you kidding me i'm i'm
literally i don't remember i was on
ketamine so it's like you know what i
mean like it's just kind of like when
you grow up doing drugs you learn how to
be like a functioning drug addict and
that's where it's like really dangerous
because it's like it's like if you can
you know function while doing it you
don't you don't really see
like
all this stuff until you start you know
getting deep into it like when you get
into a drug like fentanyl
and then you you see yourself overdose
and you know and i mean you like
recognize that like now i could you know
have brain damage and yeah you know like
it's
it's hard you know and i mean and it's
like
i think like
i don't know if i would still be here if
i didn't start using like with someone
like
you know what i mean as much as like you
know what i mean like meeting him is
what like
in a sense led me into that i feel like
the mental state i was in
like i i would have been led down that
path
regardless and i'm just glad that i like
got to experience it with someone who
cares about me and like could save my
life and stuff because
i remember last year like i went to the
psych ward and i had a whole psychosis
and stuff and
i and i remember thinking about trying
to use heroin and stuff and i'm just
like you know i think you know
everything happens for a reason and like
this is like a lesson and it's not going
to be our whole lives you know we we
really don't want to keep using we don't
want to keep doing this we don't want to
be in this because it's not fun all
right celeste and sebastian thank you so
much for sharing your stories thank you
i wish you guys the best of luck
thank you
you